do you recognize these images probably
because they were all born right here on
the internet part of an ever expanding
modern horror sub-genre Creepypasta the
origin of some Creepypastas like siren
head can be traced to a precise Moment
In Time unlike other more established
legends that are often part of oral
traditions and involves slowly over
centuries digital folklore also has the
ability to change quickly at the whim of
a single user's post or tweet even the
name Creepypasta comes from 4chan a port
Man 2 of creepy and copy pasta AKA copy
and paste the necessary gesture for
content to go viral over time
Creepypastas expanded to include things
Beyond user-generated Tales of creepy
monster sightings and personal
experiences and have really arrived in
our mainstream urban legends